ist noch was du die richtung ist klar
[Musik]
soll ich jetzt ausführen warum cannabis
legalisiert werden muss natürlich mache
ich das ja wir haben seit 50 jahren eine
provisions politik ist geschafft hat
hunderttausende von menschen in den
knast zu bringen millionen von menschen
wurden mit geldstrafen übersät einträge
in führungs solchen job verlust und und
und familien wurden zerstört infolge
einer angst die geschaffen wurde nämlich
dadurch dass man seit den siebziger
jahren mit der einzigste um theorie ja
argumentiert das hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht im jahre 1994
bereits widerlegt gleichwohl wird damit
argumentiert und raum geschmissen
weltweit vertritt dass kein
wissenschaftler